a world that's lost its way needs a
healer someone to patch up its wounds
and tend to its pain it needs a doctor
when day broke the sun turned from a
giver of life the thing that wakes the
rooster and makes the crops grow to an
indiscriminate killer wiping out all
organic life forms the world seemed
truly lost but one anomalous being made
it his goal to soothe the hurt to make
it safe to step into the light once more
the plague doctor had done his best with
the limited resources afforded to him at
the abandoned foundation site the
scientists had left behind all of their
equipment when the red sun came when
they all were transformed he had
appointed himself the site director
willing to take up the mantle when no
one else would he had assembled a brave
brilliant team of fellow anomalies the
verbose dr spenco the eloquent
adventurist lord blackwood and the
charismatic but ravenous ferdinand there
had of course been those who scoffed at
his vision who did not share his noble
goal the abominable possessive mask
taunted him persistently trying its best
to get under his kittenous skin but he
did not have time to waste on such
trivial psychological games and he
ignored its taunts to focus on the work
it hadn't been easy capturing one of the
infected specimens the former human
being turned mass of oozing gelatinous
flesh by the unholy light in the sky one
had made its way into the abandoned
facility sliding its way across the
floor with an air of confused malice it
wanted to hurt but it didn't know where
it was who it was anymore but it was
frightened the play doctor could tell a
good physician always knows and can
sense the fear and pain of a suffering
person it made his heart ate to see
and he knew there was only one thing to
do try to make this poor soul well again
everyone please assist me in escorting
the patient to my laboratory the doctor
called out this was once a man and i
believe with our combined intellect and
resources we can return him to his
former state ferdinand took a step
toward the slimy creature licking his
lips a bit do you think i could have
just a little bit of it oh i'm so hungry
doctor he begged no
no it would go against my oath as a
physician to allow any more harm to come
to this poor fellow the plague doctor
shook his head solemnly fernand pouted
but did not press the issue further no
the doctor rubbed his gloved hands
together in anticipation of the next
task it is imperative we contain our new
friend safely if you would please he
gestured to several of his previous
patients now reanimated and ready to aid
him with his research the shuffling
figure surrounded the blobby entity
ushering it down the hall confused lost
with no real sense of the plan left in
its mushy consciousness the creature
followed where it was led the group made
it back to the doctor's laboratory
shouted dr spanko from his perch atop a
nearby shelf yes indeed the doctor
replied your standard operating table
wouldn't do for such a special patient i
have nowhere to place the restraints you
see i will have to make do with the
floor ferdinand my bag if you please the
giant rushed to his side dropping the
bag at his feet if he dies then can i
eat it he asked shifting from one foot
to the other like a child asking a
parent for a second helping of ice cream
if i am unable to save the patient which
i do deem unlikely then yes you may help
me dispose of their remains the doctor
relented but i do not hope it comes to
that he pressed a hand to his beak in
deep thought for a moment before opening
his bag and pulling out a syringe filled
with clear liquid to begin we must
sedate the patient he had no way to find
a veins and so he plunged the needle
into the nearest section of the
creature's soft surface injecting a dose
of sedative then he waited the using
motion of the entity slowed and stopped
it lay there on the ground a still mound
of flesh save for the occasional
expanding and contracting motion almost
as if it was breathing excellent now
there was no risk of the patient fleeing
the operating room mid-procedure he
could truly begin it was an arduous
process that took hours of effort of
taking small tissue samples attempting
to make incisions only for the flesh to
fuse back together seconds after the
scalpel was taken away this was truly an
advanced illness unlike anything he had
ever seen before it was enough to make
him question his abilities as a doctor
but he shook the thought away self-pity
never helped anyone after about eight
hours of continuous work he had a
breakthrough a solution he had created
long ago a thick green liquid sealed in
a dusty jar had a miraculous effect when
dripped onto one of the tissue samples
the melted flesh reconstituted became
solid and human again eureka he cried
out unable to restrain the sudden joy
that leaped into his heart this could be
it very carefully he filled the dropper
with the green liquid if these initial
trials had been successful then perhaps
he couldn't finish the thought best not
to get ahead of himself he crossed to
his patient and slowly began to pour the
solution over the creature's viscous
surface he watched as the flesh
toughened coming together into a surface
resembling human skin it was working it
was
working but then the creature began to
quiver shaking uncontrollably like a
bowl of jelly in an earthquake the
surface rippled and the doctor could
hear a high-pitched wine filling the
room then with a wet pop the patient
exploded sending chunks of flesh
splattering all over the room painting
the walls and sealing the doctor cried
out in shock and horror and in spite of
himself fell to his knees in despair he
had been so close but still he had
failed and who could say when he would
find another test subject if he would
ever find a cure i'm afraid i do not
know what to do now the doctor admitted
fernand's side the next several days
passed in a haze the doctor paced around
his laboratory mulling over his possible
mistakes again and again he had rushed
the process he was certain of that now
it was a novice mistake the sort of
thing he might have done a century or
two ago how could he have been so
foolish how could he have made that
innocent pay the price for his own
hubris as the doctor locked himself away
in this mined palace fernand occupied
himself by practicing his favorite songs
lord blackwood rode on the massive man's
shoulder as he sang through the opera
don giovanni i once saw a production of
this at the teatrola venice in venice
lord blackwood interjected his
rhinopores twitching in delight at the
memory marvelous production marvelous
city i was there hunting a rogue tattle
worm wrecking havoc through the canals i
nearly lost my life on that voyage
would you all be quiet for once in your
miserable lives a voice hissed from the
shadows there in the doorway its face
fixed in the frown was the possessive
mask black slime dripped from its eye
holes spilling down onto the plastic
mannequin body it had taken hold of
listening to you both is worse than
being locked in that infernal box the
mask looked around the room searching
for someone
where is the good doctor
it asked voice dripping with the stain
still moping about counting his failures
ignore him my fine fellow lord black
would whisper to fernand only those with
weak constitutions and no achievements
of their own spend their days dragging
others down when you have lived as long
as i you will learn this
[Laughter]
careful my lord
i'll stop by the kitchen and find some
salt to pour on you
if you wish to fight me then challenge
me to a fair duel like a man the
colorful slug bellowed drawn by the
sudden shouting the doctor walked into
the room what is all this commotion
oh
good
the mask clapped its plastic hands
together its face warping back into an
eerie smile
there you are
this has all been so dreadfully boring
i came to see the remnants of your
greatest shame
are there still blood stains on the
floor in your pathetic little laboratory
you
are a villain the doctor seethed
uncomfortable with the air of conflict
in the room ferdinand and lord blackwood
quickly exited to find another space
where they could sing and share stories
in
truths peace one wants to hear
the mass crossed to the doctor's side
with a series of light dance-like steps
that made the mannequin body creak
in fact
i have quite a few truths to share today
i've been outside you see
whatever's become of the sun affects
organic beings and so
he gestured from his ceramic face to his
plastic body
i am quite safe from its rays
you've been
outside the doctor couldn't keep the
curiosity out of his voice he was a
scientist after all
oh my yes
would you like to know what i've seen
black slime dripped from the mask's
mouth pooling on the floor with a
sizzling sound i'm in no mood for tricks
the doctor warned the mask held up his
hands and mocked surrender
no tricks thunder
but if you'd rather take your chances
outside and see for yourself
i can take my leave now
no the doctor shook his head please
do tell me
it's so much worse than you could even
imagine the mask's words were bleak but
its tone was gleeful
everywhere you look up there
the light has made monsters
humans dogs cats mice the wild beasts of
the forest
all melted down into creatures you would
not even recognize
but that isn't all
no that is not all
there are massive beasts 10 feet tall or
more made from dozens and dozens of the
creatures coming together
they fuse and meld into one giant entity
roving the streets in search of more and
more bodies to add to the pile
and ooze a gaping maw of hunger and hate
that seeks only to consume and destroy
it calls out to surviving humans in the
voices of their fallen loved ones tugs
at their heartstrings to lure them out
of their hiding places
and then
it wraps around them with fleshy
tentacles pulling them in until they are
no more just another part of the monster
oh
doctor it's terror
it's an abomination
i could watch it all day
the doctor wanted to believe the mask
was lying that it was trying to torment
with him with awful fabrications but
after all he had seen so far he knew
that its words were true get out of my
sight he said or what the mask stared
him down with its unmoving smile i've
seen what you do to your hosts you know
your body won't last forever the doctor
growled hmm
true
maybe next i'll take yours
[Laughter]
the mask laughed a long dark laugh of
something ancient and evil then it
turned and walked out the door leaving
the doctor alone he spent so much of his
time that way lately his assistants were
preoccupied his former patients provided
no real company and so he did what he
did best carry on in solitude he
couldn't be sure how long he stood there
in silence thinking of what the mask
told him he knew it was dangerous
outside knew he was up against powerful
destructive forces but it was even worse
than he had thought what if the world
was truly doomed what if this was how it
all ended not with a bang but with a
great melting suddenly the doctor heard
a sound he hadn't heard since the sun
turned wrong a scream a human scream
could it be he had to see for himself he
grabbed his bag of tools and rushed down
the hall his robes fluttering behind him
there was again a different human voice
screaming in terror as he grew closer to
the sound he could hear footsteps
various other voices overlapping with
each other he rounded the corner and
there they were a group of five humans
wrapped in tattered clothes dirty and
exhausted behind them was the entrance
to what looked like a tunnel somehow
they found a secret passage and made
their way inside then he saw what made
them scream clearly these people were
afraid and unaccustomed to the sight of
a man of fernand's stature especially
when the man was drooling and staring at
them with hunger in his eyes he would
have to defuse the situation quickly
hello welcome we mean you'll no harm
strangers he stepped between fernand and
the humans the man at the front of the
group brandished a firearm pointing the
barrel directly at the doctor's peak
please sir there's no need for violence
what are you the man stammered the other
members of his party cowered behind him
an ally if you will permit me to be i'm
a physician you see working on a cure
for the condition that plagues the world
with a shaking hand the man slowly
lowered his gun he did not put it away
though you've
figured out a cure for those
things i am in the process of developing
it so far i have not been successful but
perhaps with your help how do we know we
can trust you the man demanded how am i
supposed to know you're not part of this
do you know who this man is
fernando this is dr john watson and i am
detective sherlock holmes the greatest
investigator in the world there isn't a
case we can solve the man looked at the
woman next to him and the two shared a
wide-eyed glance this this guy's crazy
he whispered furtively put your weapon
away and we can speak more calmly the
doctor proposed at this inopportune
moment a few of his revived patients
shambled into view and the man screamed
again this time he fired his weapon
shooting at one of the walking corpses
the bullets ricocheted off the walls and
several of the patients were hit please
stop with no other option the doctor
grabbed the man's arm hoping to get a
hold of the weapon and end the potential
bloodshed as soon as his gloved hand
made contact the man went limp and
dropped to the ground with a hard thud
the woman next to him pulled him into
her arms checking his pulse he's dead
she shrieked tears streaming down her
face i i am so sorry my lady i did not
intend she grabbed the man's gun and
trained it on the doctor once more you
killed him she cried the other survivors
were too shaken to speak to move one of
them had his back turned to the group
and was staring into the darkness behind
him whatever he was looking at it was
worse than the chaos unfolding but no
one noticed the beige flesh tentacle
snaking along the ground until it was
too late until it had grabbed a hold of
the man's ankle and dragged him into the
tunnel with a shriek of pure
unadulterated terror the woman nearly
dropped her gun at the sound whirling
around to see what had happened deep in
the tunnel the screen warped into a wet
gurgling sound and then there was
silence for a long moment but then
something worse a gooey slimy sound the
sound of something enormous something
soft and fleshy making its way through
the tunnel and toward the group another
tentacle curled around the edge of the
opening then another joined it something
emerged that might have once been a hand
but had melted into something
unrecognizable the monster emerged piece
by piece until the doctor could see the
entire thing it looked like a heap of
people dozens of them clambering on top
of each other wrapping their limbs
together until their flesh and insides
emptied out and fused into a shapeless
mass it moved a bit like a giant slug
slimy and slow but it seemed to know it
could take its time as the survivors
scrambled back away from it ferdinand
and the doctor taking a few steps back
of their own the sound of human voices
filled the room there were
unintelligible whispers the soft giggle
of a child a woman weeping come and be
with us a little boy's voice broke
through the cacophony mommy i miss you
don't you miss me the woman with the gun
let out a broken sob billy she sniffled
it's me mommy the innocent voice
continued emanating from somewhere deep
inside the monstrous mass that crept
along the ground swelling and grasping
with its ropey tentacles come play with
me outside all you have to do is come
outside madame the creature is not what
claims to be the doctor spoke up and it
seemed to shake the woman out of a
trance you're not my son she hissed
squeezing the trigger and firing at the
monster the bullet made contact with a
wet useless slap and disappeared into
the roving pile of the fallen she fired
again and again but the monster did not
stop it did not even slow down it lashed
out with a tentacle that wrapped around
her throat in a single fluid motion and
snapped her neck with a crack she fell
to the ground and the tentacle pulled
her into its depths until she was no
longer visible she hadn't been taken by
the sun not yet but she was still lost
the rest of the survivors followed their
screams silence one by one the doctor
felt the same overwhelming sense of
hopelessness wash over him the same
shadow that had passed over him when he
lost the last patient what could he do
he was one physician against an
overpowering force of destruction
perhaps he could touch it and would fall
dead like so many other organisms before
but what if it didn't what if instead it
wrapped around his body and squeezed the
life from him what if it carried him out
into that cursed sunlight and he melted
away like the others he had to make a
decision because the beast was advancing
toward him doctor fernand shouted it's
going to destroy our facility indeed the
creature was flailing its appendages
around beating against the walls and
trying to tear down steel and plaster
break down the shelter until they too
were exposed to the deadly light i'm
afraid this may be the end my friend the
doctor lamented i can see no hope for us
now no ferdinand shook his head let me
save us let me lead it back outside
you'll be taken the doctor cried perhaps
not i am a magnificent specimen after
all i believe i can withstand the sun
and return to continue our work together
fernand scooped his sleeping lord
blackwood from his shoulder and placed
him gingerly on a nearby shelf thank you
for your company then he turned back to
the doctor and thank you for my freedom
and your friendship
it has been an honor before the doctor
could protest ferdinand was running his
thunderous steps pounding the earth as
he led the monster in a chase it took
the bait following this new large target
back outside he sealed off the tunnel
behind them ensuring the beast would not
return the way it came he wanted to
believe ferdinand's bravado to think
that the behemoth of a man had survived
outside but that night he saw the great
beast ooze past a window and he could
make out that familiar wide toothy grin
protruding from its side just like that
the greatest assistant he had ever had
was lost thank you for your service my
friend he whispered to himself i
solemnly swear to you your death shall
not be in vain now go check out when day
breaks
scp-049 and when daybreak's scp-096
for more terrifying tales from the world
of when day breaks